مساء الخير تفاصيل كثير من الازمه
السياسيه اللي موجوده في فرنسا ربما
المتابع العربي لكن جوهر الازمه من الجميع
لانه تشابه مع الازمات اللي بتجينا في
المنطقه وبيتا شابه يعني في بعض جوانبه مع
اللي بيحصل في المغرب والاردن ومصر
والسودان وتونس ودول كثيره اقتصاداتها
مختله وتبحث عن عليه لاصلاح اقتصادها ال
مقتل الرئيس ماكرون لما تولى السلطه في
2017 ان اقتصاد بلده عنده ازمه الازمه
دينا تيجي عن انه نسب النمو ضعيفه نسبه
النمو سجلت واحد وسته من عشره نسبه
البطاله بالتالي يعني ما فيش استثمارات
وبالتالي ما فيش فرص التشغيل وبالتالي
البطاله وصلت الى تسعه واثنين من عشره
يعني تقريبا عشره مواطنين ما بين فرنسي ما
عندهمش فرص عمل وبالتالي بيكون فيه فيه
بعض التقارير بتقول انه فيه حوالي تسعه
مليون فرنسي يعانون من الفقر دراجات
المختلف وجهه نظره الينا على اصلاح هذا
الخلل لازم انه انا ازوج الاستثمارات
وعلشان اسود الاستثمارات الاستثمارات يعني
عمل مشاريع يعني علشان حل مشكله البطاله
معانا علشان تزود الاستثمارات الحل الوحيد
انك تستثمر ان يكون عندك مدخرات مدخرات
المواطنين في البنوك المحليه البنوك
الوطنيه
يتم استثمارها في مشروعات واقع الامر الى
نسبه الاستثمارات نسبه المدخرات اللي
موجوده هناك فيه عندنا مش دائما كفايه
وبالتالي هو دائما يسعى الى انه يعود نقص
المدخرات اللي مو اللي مش موجود نتيجه
اسباب كثيره اما الفارسي بعض دولنا او
الاستهلاك الشديده او الرفاهيه الشديده
لازم تستهلك
استثماراتها ما بيتوجه شيء فلوس كثير
كافي ما يكفي انه يكون فيه تراكم للثروه
وبالتالي يتم استثمار هذا القائد يبقى
البديل انا اعمل ايه انا اخرى المستثمر
الاجنبي او الاستثمارات الاجنبيه بانها
تاتي الى فرنسا فرنسا بلد جيد وعن بنيه
تشريعيه جديده وهاي الجده
هو الفرق بين وبين ما هو الفرق في الدرجه
لازم يكون المستثمرين بحافظه خليجي فرنسا
عرفش بريطانيا ما يروحش اه اه المانيا ما
يروحش الولايات المتحده الاسواق المتقدمه
وبالتالي عليهم بحوافز احد هذه الحوافز
انه يقلل عليهم الضرائب والرجل اللي عليهم
الضرائب في مقابل انه ساعه ل زياده
الضرائب على مؤيد الشعب واحد هذه الضرائب
كانت زياده الضريبه على الوقود الوقود
اللي بنعرفه احنا اللي هو البنزين
والسولار والامور تكون لها ل وعدوهم
الديزل طيب اللي عمل الضريبه الضريبه
عملها لانه اولا اه ادخل الخزانه العامه
وبالتالي يقدر ينفق على الصحه والتعليم
الى اخره كمان هو عنده حاجه ثانيه خاصه
بفرنسا انا عاوز اللي يخلي الناس تنفر من
استخدام اي وقود ملوث للبيئه اللي
اعتبارات خاصه به هو انا عاوز ويخلي فرنسا
بلد نبقى قائده في حكايه الدفاع عن البيئه
مش بس لاسباب اخلاقيه
ولكن لاسباب تتعلق بنظره هو بال حسب ال
الم والورقه هذا مكلفه الاخرى بعيدا عن
الخصوصيه الفرنسيه في القصريه
لما عمل الخطوه دي الناس فارق وطالبت
الضريبه الخاصه بال ال على البنزين هو
الرجل لم يستجب والحكومه يعني شايفه ان
اذكر ان فاضي الحركه تظاهرت الحركه اطلقوا
على نفسه ومستحضرات السفراء لانه الجدد
اللي بيبقى مرتبط ب انه الواحد بيستخدموا
للسياره موجود في سياره كل مواطن بيسوق
العربيه وبالتالي المطالب ذلك
حولت مع الغضب ومع دخول عناصر مختلفه الى
عمليه تخريب واسعه والتركمان تزيد المطالب
خلاصه المطالبه بعدم وقف الزياده في ال
الضريبه على البنزين ولكن
انه في معبر واحد من اللي موجودين من
اصحاب السيطرات ال السفراء ال احنا مطلبنا
الاساسي ان احنا نعيش وبدنا نفكر بحزب
التجمع اللي كان موجود في مصر الحزب
اليساري من ثلاثين سرعه الحاجه لما كان
بيقول الحكومه خطوه وان فقه علينا يعني
عندما تدين شاكر انا على وتشربني وتعلمي
الى اخره لكن المطلب الرئيسي وبالمناسبه
رئيس الوزراء تراجع لما تراجع النهار ده
انا بكلمك م النهار دا يوم ال اه الاربع
الموافق 4 ديسمبر
رئيس الوزراء الفرنسي تراجع تراجع نسبيا
اجل كل الزيارات سته اشهر قادمه
وقال كمان حاجه ثانيه انه هذه المظاهرات
اللي هم انكروها وسخر وامنها في البدايه
هي ناتجه عن شعور عميق بالظلم وعدم
المساواه
حتى هذه اللحظه هي التجربه او الحاله
الفرنسيه وما اعتقدش هل الازمه انتهت
الازمه سوف يكون لها ذيول اخرى لانه
الرئيس الفرنسي معليش الاقتصاد الفلسطيني
ما عليش الخلل في الاقتصاد وكمان ما قدر
شيء ولا تراجع تماما وبالتالي الناس قد
تستمر في المظاهرات ها في المستقبل لغايه
ما يتراجع الرئيس اذا تراجع يبقى فيه
مشاكل اخرى ابسطها انه مع المشكله
الاقتصاد الفرنسي
تشابه بيننا وبين فرنسا مع وجود سنوات فرق
بين اقتصادنا
ومستوى الناس و مستوى الاقتصاد ومع كل
الفروق بين فرنسا البلد المتقدم وبين
التشابك هو انه الوصفه واحده الحكومات هنا
في المنطقه مع وجود الفرق علشان ما حدش
يعني اوجه التشابه في الاطار العام
والحكومات والحكومات في ال فرنسا والحكومه
في العالم الغربي كلها واقعه
تحت اطار واحد او بيشتغل كله في منظومه
واحده علشان تفهموا وجهه نظره سوداويه
من نهايه السبعينات وبدايه الثمانينات
طبعا العالم كله بيحكوا مع عشرات السنوات
النظام نظام السوق المفتوحه والراسماليه
زي ما تكلمنا قبل كده لكن نظام السوق
المفتوحه وراس مال
مدارس متعدده وتوجهات مختلفه
والاقتصاد اللي موجود الراسمالي اللي
موجود في علمانيه مش هو اللي موجود في
بريطانيا مش هو اللي موجود بالضبط في
الولايات المتحده اوجه مختلفه لكن النظام
اللي ساد في العالم من نهايه السبعينات
وبدايه الثمانينات هو نظام الليبراليه
الجديده المقصود بالليبراليه الجديده
باختصار شديد تراجع دور الدوله الى اقصى
حد ممكن
واطلاق دور وايد القطاع الخاص الى ابعد
مدى ممكن يبقى القطاع الخاص الدوله تنسحب
لا تشارك لها في مصانع وعلى الاستثمارات
ولا ولا ولا في اي شيء ولا تدير مدارس ولا
مستشفيات القطاع الخاص يه من كل شيء وان
دور الدوله يقتصر فقط على تنظيم هذا السوق
الكبير وانه كمان ان الحكومه تعهدت الى
القطاع الخاص بادوار لم يكن احد يتخيل ها
هي احيانا مثلا ان هي تدير السهوله وتبني
السجون تبديها للحكومه ان هي تتولى كثير
من اعمال الامن احيانا شركات امن تقوم
بادوار كثيره ما بيمشي فيها البوليس
النظامي انه هي تقوم بالاشراف على الطرق
والكباري
وطبعا كل دوله يعني على حسم هي بتطبق ال
الفتره كلها ولا انها لكن تم نظمت اللي
السيد في العالم من نهايه السبعينات
والثمانينات اللي تكلمنا عليه في كثير من
ال حل مشكله
انه في ظل هذا النظام بتكون الحكومات
اوجه التشابه بين فرنسا ان الحكومه بيكون
قدراتها محدوده جدا يعني حتى لو الحكومه
راغبه انهى تتبع مختلفا وقرارات تخدم فيها
المواطنين بتكون قدرتها محدوده لانه كل
القوى الفاعله وكل القرارات ال مثلا باتت
بدينا القطاع الخاص والقطاع الخاص تتحول
بس مش الى مجرد رجل اعمال يفتح شركه تحول
في شكل شركات عملاقه ضخمه جدا عابره
للحدود وعبرها
القرارات الحدود الدول والقرار وبالتالي
اصبحت هي التي تتحكم في حركه المال وهي
اللي تفرض شروطها على كل الدول اذا كان
الدوله من الدول مثلا او تاخذ قرارا بفرض
ضريبه اكثر مما تقبله الشركه الكبيره
الشركات الكبيره يعني احنا بنتكلم على
شركات دين لم يكن احد يحلم به شركات
قيمتها السوقيه تصل الى الف مليار دولار
زي مثلا بنتكلم على تتكلم على ان نتكلم
على الشركه دي
يعني لما اتكلم على الف مليار دولار يعني
تقريبا ثلاث او اربع اضعاف انجيلا لبلد
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي الى اكبر بلد عربي
من حيث عدد السكان في العالم العربي وهي
مصر بتكلم على رقم خرافي هذه الشركات
عندها شركه مصالح كبيره جدا وعندها مصالح
في كل مكان في العالم وبالتالي هي
قوانينها ورغبتها اما بشكل مباشر ب قانوني
او بشكل غير مباشر على الحكومات وبعيدا عن
التعقيدات كلها في النهايه حتى لو يعني
غير ما ندخل في الزي هي بتستخدم قوانينها
والتحكيم الدولي والمنظمات الدوليه التي
تحمي مصالح وبتحمل ولا احنا ب باختصار اذا
الدوله العالم كله تحول ان وعلى انه يحابي
ويحاول استرضاء هذه الشركه لانه اذا لم
يسترضيها اتفضل انها تدخل برؤوس اموال ها
من البلاء الى مكان اخر
وبالتالي هو اللي دائما الحقيقه الوصفه
اللي موجوده ان انت كبلد اذا كنت انت عاوز
انت تحسنا وضعت الاقتصاديه لازم
تجزم المستثمر الاجنبي عشان تجذب المستثمر
الاجنبي عندك عده امور لازم تعمل ها واحد
من الامور دي ان كل ازمتها بنيه تشريعيه
كل الامور ممتاز ولازم كمان تستثمر بسخاء
في البنى التحتيه يعني اعمل ايه يعني طرق
وامريكا باري وبنا محطه كهرباء وعندما
محطات واعملوا الامور كلها تستفيد ايه
تستفيد انه المستثمر لما يجي على اي مكان
مناسب يستثمر فيه فالحكومه تقترب وتمنى
بنيه تحتيه
وبدون ساحليه على امل للمستثمرين
المستثمر بعد كل العالم يتبع نفس الكلام
الارجنتيني بتاعك ده والمغرب تعمل كده مصر
بتعمل الكلام والسوداني يطلبوا منها تعمل
كده والاردن تعمل كلها كل الوصفات من
صندوق النقد الدولي والبنك الدولي وكل
المؤسسات وكل المر والمؤسسات اه استثمر في
البنيه التحتيه بعد ان استثمر في البنيه
التحتيه مش مطلوب للحكومه تسرع ولكن يبقى
دورها انهى تنظم وتعمل الاشاعات ودعم
البنيه التحتيه سواء هي او يشجع اخرين على
ما عمل البنيه التحتيه كل الدول بتعمل
البنيه التحتيه
بيخليها بتبعيه اسيره
للاستثمار الاجنبي لاننا استثمرت كل
الفلوس عملتش فيها الاسراع ولا السلام
ولكن انا اقول انه هو يجي لما هو بايدي
بعد القاره المغرب شويه احسن هنا لمصر
احسن هناك اروح الاردن تم اروح فرنسا تم
اروح تركيب بلاش الاسواق النشاط لهم مش
عارفين اصبح المستثمر دائما في وضع فيه
جدا يغير ويختار ما يشاء وما يريد اذا
اغضبته ما يخرج ده معناه اللي قدرت
الحكومه نفسها بقيت محدوده لما تتامل
الموقف بالشكل ده كان حقيقه الامر انه
اصبح النظام الجديد او الليبراليه الجديده
وتضرب بالاساس فكره الديمقراطيه في مقتل
ديمقراطيه فكرتها الناس تروح الانتخابات
وتختار حكومه فاعله في تنفيذ اراده الشعب
الحكومه لو كانت صادقه في تنفيذ اراده
الشعب في احيان كثيره
انها سوف تعجز عن مواجهه رغبات واولويات
الشركات الكبيره والامثله لا تقع تحت حصل
عندنا وفي اماكن اخرى
راس المال الاجنبي عاوز ايه والحكومه
مضطره ولا الوقت انها تدي له وتطبق عليه
انا بقول الكلام ده كله ان الحكومه عاجزه
في ظل النظام اللي موجود
اذا يفترض ان الحكومه عندها كفاءه وعندها
نزاهه تبقى هي عاجزه الى حد كبير لكن واقع
الامر ان وجد اؤمن الصوره كذا احيانا تكون
ان الحكومه مش بس عاجزه بحكم ان جزء من
المنظومه العالميه اللي بدء من نهايه
السبعينات احنا بتكون الحكومه الغربيه او
خائنه
الشعب اللي اتمنى غربيه بان هي مش قادره
ابدا تدير القصه بشكل معقول و تعمل توازن
ما بين يعني زاي انا احفظ المستثمرين وزي
لما احفظ احفظ الاستثمارات ممكن تنفعني
بحيث انه في النهايه المستثمر لما بيجي
المستثمر المحلي والمستمر الخارجي ممكن او
صفه فيما احزابه هي مش قادره تعمل دائم
مستسلمه تماما
وكل اللي بتعمل وانهى ب تجري وراءهم
تبقى جزء من اولويات هم جزء من اجل تهمه
جزء من اجندته وحرب يكون هو اكثر من
الحكومه الانسان حكومه خائنه
بمعنى انه انه المسؤولين اللي
وبيشوفوا الدنيا مش زاي هذه الشركات هي
اللي بتدفع تبرعات اذا كانوا مستثمرين
محليين كبار رجال اعمال كبار ومستثمرين
دوليين هما دول اللى بيدفعوا
الحملات الانتخابيه لو كانت فيها انتخابات
او هي البلد هي اللي ت دفع رشاوى
تقولين في البلاد اللي ما يهم ومش
الانتخابات ومن الضروري وهما دول اللي بدو
واولادهم وهما دول اللي بيوقفوا المسؤولين
لما بالخروج من المنصب اذا خرجوا بيوظف
اولادهم وبالتالي كثير من الاحيان الحكومه
صحيح دورها تنظيمي على الورق كلام جيد
للحكومه نظم والقطاع الخاص هذا يبقى جيد
جدا لكل الاطراف ولكن الحكومه فشل في
الاداره وفشله في ال ال كصانع مزارع
الامور الى القطاع الخاص جيد وتم بشكل جيد
لكن احيانا بتعمل التنظيمات والتشريعات
اتحادي هذه الشركات وتعطيها اكثر من حقها
تكون النتيجه ظلم كبير واقع على الطبقات
الفقيره اللي انا بقول ان النظام
انه مظاهر فشل متعدده سواء مع تكرار
الازمات الماليه والاقتصاديه الكثيره
واخرها ازمه الازمه الماليه العالميه في
2008 النظام الفاشل بسبب عدم المساواه او
التفاوض ال
الفقر في الاجور والدخول وانا اقول
لحضراتكم كده مثلا الاقسام المنظمه
البريطانيه المعنيه
بالمساواه في العالم بتقول ان اثنين
واربعين شخصا في 2017 يملكوا ما يعادل
ثروه نصف سكان الارض النصف الفقير من سكان
الارض سكان الارض الصوم ثلاثه وسبعه من
عشره ثلاثه وسبعه من عشره ونصف الفقير
واحد وواحد من عشره مليون جنيه استرليني
الى ان المنظمه بريطانيه حسن لها بال
استرليني الى اثنين واربعين شخصا يملكه
11 10 مليون جنيه استرليني حضرتكم تقرير
اكثر يعني او رقم مره اكثر يعني فجاجه انه
وفقا لل بنك كريدي سويس في سبعين في
المائه من سكان الارض ثرواتهم تقر ارواح
ما بين
عندوش ولا مليم وعشره الاف دولار فقط دون
سبعين في المائه من سكان الارض وثلاثين في
المائه المحافظين
عطهم يعني اكثر من عشر دولار يعني ممكن
المحظوره يبقى عنده عشره الاف او حداشر
الف دولار والمحجوز الثاني عنده مائه
مليار دولار لان بردو المساله مش بال يعني
في تفاوت خطير جدا في كل الاحوال الكلام
اذا كرمال لكن النتيجه انه في عدم عداله
وبالتالي فيه شعور عميق
رئيس الوزراء الفرنسي النتيجه ان الشعوب
تتاهب للثوره في اقرب فرصه تضعف فيها
الحكومه
حكومتنا اللي عندنا سواء في المنطقه وفي
العالم اما حكومات عاجزه مش قادره تعمل
حاجه مع المنظمه السائد حضراتكم خفيه مش
قادره تدير ال ال الصلاحيات المحدوده لها
او متامره وخائنه ان تشوف حكومه حضرتك
واللي ان تحكم من وجهه نظرك عجزها فقط ولا
عاجزه وغبيه والعجزه وغربيه وخائنه العالم
يفضل يعني في ظل هذا النظام حتى يستطيع
انه يد النظام الاخر
بيدور حواليه جوهر التغيير في النظام
العالمي الجديد
اشكركم والى لقاء اخر
[موسيقى]